there's something i've been thinking a  lot about lately which is like with  everything that's going on with me  i talk a lot about not hearing the booze  i don't give a [ __ ] what you think but  it goes both ways i also don't hear the  accolades  like so many people as my notoriety and  awareness grows and things that are  going on with me i was like man you're  so humble and every time i hear somebody  say that i say it's because i can't hear  your booze that is literally what  happens when somebody you know because  they don't expect it especially the way  i am on video and on stage they get  confused by like the humility when they  actually get to know me sure and i'm  like and it's so funny how intuitive i  feel that's completely laddered to me  not hearing people that [ __ ] on me